hi everyone we will be uh join starting
the free career Master Class session uh
few in few minutes meanwhile uh we are
just uh doing a quick of introductions
on the chat here so I am Rasha Khan I am
your host for today's webinar and I'm
joining all the way from Bangalore India
I would love to know where are you
tuning in from not only me for folks who
actually have started joining us already
uh so you can let us know your name and
where are you tuning in from uh and uh
interact a bit Network a bit before we
start right so uh let's just introduce
ourselves on the chart here and also as
we are nearing towards the end of the
year as well so uh you can let us know
also like what are your career
resolutions which you're planning for
next year so we'll start in 2 three
minutes meanwhile let's get settled in
before we start I see a lot of new folks
are joining in so
uh let's uh start the session in few
minutes so today we'll be talking about
uh game changing emerging Tech in cyber
security for
2024 I see uh introductions have already
started coming
in for the chat here I see Sai Kumar has
joined us from Hyderabad NES has joined
from Bangalore Amit has joined us from
Hyderabad and
uh
and also I see uh Paris Aurora a speaker
today has also joined us already and
prit has joined us from Hyderabad we are
also live on our YouTube channel as well
we streaming live there as well so uh
folks who have joined us on YouTube uh
we have a very interesting session lined
up for you and also please do share your
introductions uh on the chat YouTube
live chat box as well we'll be looking
at the YouTube live chat box as well and
also uh if you have any questions as
well please feel free to uh put on your
question from the YouTube live chat as
well we taking questions from there as
well I see uh anes has
introduced themselves on the chat
YouTube live chat and is joining from
biar Patna I see nakaru has is joining
from Hyderabad on YouTube live chat box
and also a lot of you folks are are
joining in so please do share your
introductions on the chat here we'll
start the session uh writing for
minutes
uh I see more introductions coming in on
chat here uh and I can see someone is
asking can't make out your name from
email ID so sorry for that uh will this
master class be accessible later yes it
will be uh you'll be getting getting a
recording of the session uh post webinar
and uh I'm seeing a lot of introductions
coming on the YouTube live chat box as
well so folks who have joined us on
YouTube uh welcome uh a very good
evening uh to everyone uh so so let me
quickly take you through a few quick
ground rules we have here for the
session so in case you have any question
for a speaker par aora who has already
joined us today um you can put down your
questions in the Q&A box and for folks
who have joined us on YouTube you can
put on your questions on the YouTube
live chat box and only thing is just
keep the questions related to cyber
security or the program we'll be
covering that's all because today's
session is all about cyber security and
emerging gamechanging emerging uh Tech
in cyber security will be covering that
we have an interesting session lined up
for you also the session is being
recorded in case you want to go through
the recording of the session again in
case you missed something or if you like
something so much that you want to watch
it again so yes you can expect a
followup email with recording link and
uh webinar certificate as well and uh
sidhart has asked like will we get
certificate for the webinar yes you will
get you need to stay till the end and
also put on your full name in the post
webinar survey now what exactly is the
post webinar survey uh once basically uh
the zoom session ends here which is of
60 Minutes duration you will get an
immediate popup from Zoom uh for a post
webinar survey where you can put down
your full name uh the name which you
would want to see in the certificate and
also uh you will be getting a feedback
uh basically option as well in case you
have any feedback for us uh you can let
us know how because we would love to
make our webinars better so we can
provide more value to you as well so uh
thank you everyone I see a lot of
introductions coming in on chat and also
for our YouTube live chat box as well so
welcome once again uh uh today's program
is powered by simply learn world's
number one online board camp we have
been in the digital skills training
space for almost 13 years now and we are
very proud of transforming lives by
empowering people VI are these skills we
have advanced over five lakh plus
careers in over 150 plus countries we
have over 800 plus qualified trainers we
have categories of courses ranging from
AI machine learning data science
business antic cyber security first
stack development and many more like
that so today we'll be talking about
cyber
security and uh before we move on uh let
me quickly take you through the agenda
of today's session uh we'll be getting
to know a little bit more about you how
we can help you out in your career
better we'll be talking about immersion
Technologies and cyber security in 2024
uh and we'll be talking about careers in
cyber security in 2024 we'll be talking
about the I campus program which gets
you jobity and also taking through the
enrollment steps of the program also
there will be a special duration for the
Q&A part so in case uh you have any
question for our speaker today uh in in
related to cyber security career or the
program by ID kpur you can let us know
in the Q&A box and we'll try to address
all of your queries as much as possible
and folks who have joined us on YouTube
can let us know in the uh chat box here
and we'll try to take up questions from
there so uh before we start as I
mentioned we'll get to know you a little
better so let's start for a quick poll
here we have for you so uh poll which
you can see here on the screen here and
which is launched right now uh says how
many years of experience do you
currently have so you can see four quick
options of the poll here on zoom and for
folks who have joined us on YouTube here
we can just refer to these options here
the first one is currently studying
second one is 0 to three years third one
3 to 5 years uh fourth one more than
four years so uh when I talk about
experience here I'm talking about work
experience here so you can let us know
through this poll here let's get to know
each other a little better we usually
get a lot of folks coming from different
different set of
experiences uh so I I'll just give 15
seconds for the poll here and also for
the folks who have joined us live on
YouTube as well to let us know how many
years of experience do you currently
have and also to introduce yourself in
case you not in introduce yourself on
the chat
here
I see most of the folks have already
shared their responses for the poll here
how many years of experience do you have
uh for a few of the folks who are still
sharing uh please uh STI quickly go and
have a look uh at the poll which I
launched and please do share us your
responses last 10 seconds folks before
we start with the
session
awesome I think most of the folks have
already shared responses for the poll so
let me quickly end the poll last five
seconds five 4 3 2
1 and also share the results with you
folks so as you can see that uh 37 of
the 37% of the folks who have joined us
have more than five years of experience
32% of the folks who have joined us are
currently studying 24% of the folks who
have joined us have three to0 to three
years of experience and 8% of the folks
have 3 to five years of experience so as
I mentioned earlier we uh usually get
folks joining us from different
different set of experiences and always
good to have a diverse uh crowd here and
uh folks on on YouTube as well I see you
have basically shared your responses on
the live chat box as well so thank you
for sharing that with us U and now I
would like to welcome uh speaker Paris
Aurora uh today uh for the career Master
Class session uh so welcome Paris it's
always uh a pleasure hosting you and to
have you uh for these webinars uh yours
is always an interesting one and we have
an interesting to topic lined up today
uh which folks definitely will be
enjoying I'm sure uh so would you like
to give us your uction for the crowd
here sure thank you so much Rasha for
having me here and thank you everyone
for joining this webinar as well so my
name is Dr parz and I have been uh kind
of uh into this industry for a little
over 19 years now and uh I started my
career Journey from an IT
standpoint uh wherein I started working
on the Microsoft Technologies and then
later on transitioned into the Unix
world then databases and application
development and so on before I
eventually discover my passion within
cyber security and uh have been into the
cyber security industry for about 14
years now uh dedicated to the uh to the
cyber world now within the cyber
security itself have seen multiple faces
of the stream of the study in terms of
the compliances in terms of uh the
governance and risk as well along with
the technical side of the cyber world as
well so have been into various streams
of cyber security have worked with many
Global organizations like Verizon like
PWC and Microsoft currently so yeah have
been into this industry and totally love
uh love my job throughout the day and
happy to be here on this webinar hosting
you all here along with
Russia thank you so much po uh thank you
for your introduction uh let's move on
and let's start with talking about the
emerging Technologies and cyber Security
in 2024 so uh so over to your
pass thank you Rasha and I would say see
from the emerging technology standpoint
uh there are a lot of uh changes that we
are seeing there's a lot of Buzz there's
lot of talk that we are seeing on the
artificial intelligence and the Machine
learning which is AI and ml in short now
while Ai and ml have obviously found
their way into a lot of technological
advancements in terms of the natural
learning processing or in terms of a
deep learning and so on there are
multiple use cases that we can see with
getting adopted within the information
security or the cyber security world as
well some of it relates to the IDR which
is intrusion detection and response
malware detection and threat hunting as
well now traditionally the IDR systems
which is intrusion detection and
response systems have relied on Purely
the rule based and the signature based
techniques wherein we can create a rule
we can create a signature and if the
rule and signature matches then it can
raise an alarm as an intrusion within
the
environment however which I mean these
traditional techniques have not
effectively detected the new threats or
they have not adopted to changing the
attack patterns as well therefore the
world is now moving to the AI and ml
techniques to enhance the accuracy and
efficiency of the IDR systems
uh some of the techniques which are
being used within the IDR system from
AIML standpoint uh stands to be anomaly
DET detection wherein it's a very very
prevalent AI based intrustion detection
approach uh which identifies the
deviations from the system standard
Behavior Uh so anything which is of a
deviation would be marked as a potential
security threat it may not be a
confirmed security but a potential
security threat
uh this particular technique can be
applied through diverse methods such as
the statistical analysis the distance
metrics uh the density based algorithms
and so on so it is pretty much prevalent
today the other side of it or the other
mechanism through which the IDR has
adopted or is being researched to adopt
a IML is via supervised and the
unsupervised learning as well now what
happens within the super wised learning
is uh this this particular technique
entails the training the machine
learning models on the labeled data uh
to identify the patterns predict the
future outcomes and so on so there's a
large data set to which the machine
learning model are exposed to and then
because the data is labeled the models
can easily detect and identify which is
a potential data to be secured and which
is not not to be secured or which is not
too risky so as to say so so yeah I mean
these models do exist uh some of the
algorithm includes the decision trees
the neural networks and uh the support
Vector machines as well these are some
commonly employed learning techniques in
the intrusion detection as
well now uh when we talk about the
unsupervised learning this is where the
things becomes a little tricky where
where in while in the supervised model
the data is labeled in unsupervised
learning the data is not labeled so
which mean there's lot of unstructured
data there's lot of unlabeled data as
well and the the models or the AI
technique has to identify the patterns
in that unlabeled data without any prior
knowledge or labeling uh so these
methods do exist uh in terms of the
intrusion detection and response
the second area where the AIML plays a
lot of key value system is in terms of a
malware detection wherein it can detect
the malwares and the anomalies through
deep learning and sble learning Behavior
based analysis which is pretty much
prevalent even today in terms of the
edrs and stuff and the natural language
processing now while these are some
common ways uh to have the malare
detection done through a IML they have
their own pros and cons uh for instance
in the Deep learning the uh the
mechanism or the model can identify the
complex patterns and the features but
the downside is you need to have a very
very large amount of data that you can
expose the model to because until or
unless you have a large model or a large
data for a model to read and recognize
you don't really get the value of a deep
learning the second method which is in
assemble learning uh this is great
theoretically because uh it has multiple
it's it's basically a combination of
multiple models for improved performance
so you get the power of let's say almost
all the models which are available but
then computationally it becomes very
very expensive so not so practical in
terms of the
implementation then comes the behavior
based analysis wherein you can detect
the U unknown map malware because it's a
behavioral thing but then what if the
malware is benign and it is hiding the
traces or it's it's keeping silent till
the time some trigger
happens so it it becomes a little
difficult to identify the benign and the
malicious behavior uh in the behavior
based analysis and then the natural
language processing it it's great to
identify any off fiscated code but at
the same time it offers a very limited
applicability to certain types of
malware because uh not all the malwares
are uh kind of offis cating the the
actual code they can be the real code as
well so very very limited in terms of
the
applicability uh so yeah these are some
of the challenges that we see from the
malware detection standpoint now when it
comes to a threat hunting uh this is
something which is very interesting
because it has got multiple
perspectives uh to it so for example a
threat hunting not necessarily becomes
identifying a threat and hunting a kind
of a you know stake out of a hay but
then at the same time threat hunting is
also about sharing the information and
knowledge about the threats that you
have already identified how those uh
information or that intelligence can be
shared and leveraged by the other
organizations as well so it is not only
about threat hunting it is also about
the threat
distribution uh it is also about the
threat prediction systems as well so
threat huntings basically hunting
basically entails a proactive approach
to identify the signs of compromise any
adversarial activity within the
organization
infrastructure and so on so these are
really cool things from a hacker
standpoint even from a you know kind of
a Ive prevention standpoint as well uh
so the threat hunting do take the
benefit of the natural language
processing for the textual data
analysis uh we do can Leverage The Deep
learning algorithms for the pattern
recognition and we can also do a graph
analysis for identifying the
intersection and the inrees between the
network relationships as well so these
are the mechanisms which are available
from from a thread hunting standpoint
and uh it's it's good to use all of this
but then some of the challenges that
comes with uh the natural language
processing for example uh can be related
to the data quality accuracy and
integrity uh but at the same time these
are some of the models which are
available so so yes the adoption of AI
and ml in security is practical it can
be done and it definitely would play a
lot of changing roles and Game Changer
from the uh prevention from evolving
threats perspective in the coming
future uh thank you so much P for taking
the first emerging technology in cyber
security let's move on to the next one
zero trust
architecture so this one I would say
it's it's already emerged I would say
but then U the adoption of zero trust
architecture is really important it
fundamentally believes in in um three
basic principles and uh the first one is
verify the explicitly uh who you want to
authenticate why you want to
authenticate what role the individual
will get an authorization upon and so on
so verify explicitly that's one so don't
assume that's the Mantra the second
principle is of using the least
privilege excess and this particular
principle has been in the cyber and the
information security world for long so
usage of the least privilege access
means you do not have access to any
infrastructure or any application or any
data but at the time that you need the
exess you have a jit which is just time
just in time excess request somebody
approving it based on the rational that
you have given and then based on the
approvals you are getting access to the
particular system or a data set now what
that means is you need to have some kind
of a processing mechanism you need to
have the approval mechanism as well so
that the the just in time excess uh
should not get delayed it should not
become hindrance to the availability of
the data as well so so you need to set
up the processes you need to set up the
systems in a way wherein uh you do not
have the access but people can get the
exess based on the requirement the third
principle is you assume that you have
already you are already compromised uh
be it an individual be it an
organization level always assume that
you are already compromised and that's
the end of it uh by assuming that you
are already compromised you are
basically building up your resilience
you are basically building up your fort
of security controls wherein uh there
are levels of security that an
individual has to pass through before
they can even see the data so assume
that you are breach so these are some uh
principles from a zero trust
architecture standpoint some of the
implementation let's say at a network
level include uh microland segmentation
as well wherein you create a lot of
small small networks uh wherein the
users are confined to let's say 10
systems or or a network of 10 system and
if they have to communicate to another
Network they have to authenticate they
have to go through the policy checks and
the need assessment as well uh so you
can you can apply the zero trust
architecture but then by applying a zero
trust architecture one needs to identify
a very sweet spot and a balance between
the need and the want so if security is
your priority I would say zero trust
architecture is the way to go but at the
same time if the usability or
functionality or the convenience of a
user service is the need then zero trust
architecture may not be the right choice
so you need to find the right balance
between the security and the usability
but uh the zero trust architecture do
play an important role in certain
industries as well like for example oil
and gas industry uh which is a critical
infrastructure from a nation security
standpoint as well so it definitely
plays out a major major role
there uh as you move on to the next
emerging technology here Quantum safe
cryptography so this one is really
interesting one and the reason I say so
is uh cryptography today for example is
in itself is a very very vast topic now
the moment we talk about cryptography
the first thing that I remember of my
older days is the RS algorithm where
there was a multiactor authentication
Hardware key so the number keeps on
changing onto the hardware and then any
authentication that I had to do on the
server system had to go through the
series of authentication measures so it
started off I mean my memory of
cryptography started starts off from
that point but having said so the
cryptography today is safe uh is it 100%
the answer is no there's nothing called
100% Safety and Security uh which exist
even today but uh there is a study that
was done by the nist on the cryptography
itself on the postquantum cryptography
which says that the first breach of the
public key or uh the pki infrastructure
can come as soon as 2030 which means
that while we are developing the quantum
computers the capacity of those
computers would be such that they will
be able to break the pki infrastructure
which is a public key infrastructure uh
as soon as by 2030 so it is a
possibility which is researched
uh at the same time Dr Michelle from
University of watero has quoted that uh
I have estimated a one in seven chance
that some of the fundamental public key
cryptography tools upon which we rely
today will be broken by 2026 so it is
even earlier than what nist is
predicting which suggest that there are
few efforts there are efforts which are
being directed
towards de towards breaking the
cryptography which exists today from a
pki infrastructure at the same time
there are efforts to secure the future
as well and some of the examples that we
see from a future safe or a Quantum safe
cryptography includes a c crystals um
kyber crystals
delu Falcon and spinix plus these are
some of the
algorithms which have been nominated
which have been selected by the ni IST
to be standardized for the quantum safe
cryptography so this particular topic is
is interesting one because this is
something which is preserving our future
so yeah there is there are a lot of
developments which are happening in this
domain uh thank you so much for taking
us through this Quantum safe
cryptography technology let's move on to
the next one here blockchain
security so the moment I hear about
blockchain uh immediately uh the you
know the kind of uh Bell that Rings into
my mind relates back to ethereum which
is like a cryptocurrency or Bitcoin
which is like a cryptocurrency again uh
but this blockchain technology has been
there in in the industry for a while now
and uh there are a lot of development
that has happened into the blockchain
security Now the blockchain in itself is
based on three principles of consensus
cryptography and the
decentralization so there is there has
to be a kind of a vote bank for any new
node or any new block to be attached to
the blockchain uh the entire blockchain
is based on the cryptography uh wherein
uh the nodes the the blocks itself the
data is secured from the encryption
standpoint and then the decentralization
in terms of The Ledger how decentralized
way The Ledger is maintained across the
blocks of data now there are three types
of blockchains that exist today in terms
of the private blockchain public
blockchain and the Consortium blockchain
as well the private blockchain I would
say is the most isolated and the
segmented one wherein for any party to
join the blockchain it has to be done
via an invitation so it is not open to
all so it is a private blockchain which
isolates the rest of the network with
the with the block blockchain
implementation the second one is the
public blockchain where anybody can go
and join uh the public blockchain uh so
this particular blockchain
implementation focuses on the
participation and the
transparency uh the transaction
consensus in the public blockchain is
decentralized which means that anyone
can participate in validating the
network transaction and the software
code for the implement ation of a public
blockchain is also open- source so it is
available to public example of the
public blockchain includes your Bitcoin
and the ethereum that I was talking
about so it is open in public people can
go participate in the Bitcoin and the
ethereum mining as well and they can uh
they can be a part of the
blockchain the third one is the
Consortium blockchains now typically
when we are talking about the
blockchains uh normal implementation
includes cludes the public and the
private one uh however this Consortium
blockchain it is consist of the known
participants which are pre-approved so
in the private blockchain It Is by
invitation so I for example I don't know
Russia but somebody has recommended me
rasia so I have invited Russia to
participate in the blockchain but in the
Consortium blockchain the individuals or
the the people who are party to the
blockchain are already pre-approved so
there is no invitation there is uh no
invite being sent out to Russia Russia
automatically inherits the the access to
the Consortium blockchain so these are
typically for the uh for example
consider a bank where you are already
having an account so you would become a
part of a Consortium blockchain once
they move on to it because they know you
already so there there is a trust which
is already there and they don't have to
invite you to be part of it rather they
do it at the back end and you become a
part of the Consortium blockchain
automatically some of the security
methods which can be used for the
protection of the blockchain data
includes uh keeping the transaction data
encrypted at both the ends which is the
nature and the behavior of the
blockchain the second one is by doing a
rigorous background check of an
individual uh who wants to part of
become a part of the block chain itself
the third one is creating the rules for
uh let's say the public blockchain if I
create a rule that particular individual
profiled individual can become a part of
the blockchain So based on those rules
there's a smart contract that gets
signed up and the fourth one is
obviously the usage of the private uh
blockchain wherein the uh the things are
literally hidden uh from everyone and U
it's only Only By Invitation so so yeah
that's how that's how I think from a
blockchain security
standpoint uh thank you so much Paris
for taking us to the blockchain security
uh now let's talk about 5G security here
as one of the emerging texts in cyber
security in
2024 so 5G is interesting security not
security but I would say the
communication protocol which is uh which
is coming up and uh from a speed
perspective from a reliability
standpoint from resilience standpoint
this is going to be a game changer
protocol in in the communication world
now while the 5G uh focuses on the speed
of the data delivery as well there is a
underlying architecture which secures
the entire transaction or the
communication um so as to
say so uh from a 5G from a 5G
uh principle standpoint resiliency
privacy communication security identity
management and security Assurance these
are some of the principles from uh the
5G security
standpoint uh now when the 5G
infrastructure got started to be built
up so from its Inception standpoint
there were few considerations which were
given in terms of the traffic Integrity
protection that was one of the uh
infrastructure security consideration
the second one was on the subscriber
privacy the third one on the identity
concealment of the subscriber how to
kind of isolate the uh identity of the
subscriber from the rest and then the
roaming interface and the payload
security along with the mutual
authentication and encryption of the key
interfaces so these are some of the
underlying thought process from the 5G
security standpoint having said so if if
we really look at the diagram or a
communication diagram at the bottom of
the right slide uh that's how the entire
5G model from a security standpoint
today or in future would look like uh
wherein you have the uh you have the
devices and the gateways you have the
access and the network you have
application Cloud infrastructure
identity management for the users so
these are all the verticals that the
security layers are divided into now
while there are verticalized security
models there are also a systemwide
security model which is a horizontal
security uh that cut across all the four
verticals which means that there is a
security which is getting baked into the
infrastructure at a horizontal layer be
from a cloud infrastructure standpoint
be it from a network standpoint be it
from an application Level security
perspective or any interconnection
standpoint so there's a systemwide
security layer which is being developed
along with the vertical security which
is in terms of the cloud native so for
example if I have taken an AWS uh as a
cloud then how I am securing the AWS
instances of my deployment along with
what the cloud provider is providing the
native security so that defines the
virtualized or the cloud native uh
security element the other one can be an
application or an appliance-based
functions uh in terms of the units of
the security that we would put on the
applications as well uh the applications
can be in terms of the infrastructure
applications or it can be uh in terms of
the hardware that we put from a receiver
and a transponder and a transmitter
perspective so how those Securities are
being looked into and then uh the
distributed cloud and the edge Computing
as well so these are some of the the
vertical levels uh security components
that are that are being talked about
while there is a systemwide security
component as well which is being biged
into uh thank you so much par for taking
us to the 5G security uh of the emerging
tech tech which we have talked about so
we have covered a lot of emerging techs
which will be basically in demand in
2024 and Beyond how can we miss talking
about careers in cyber security the
hottest Trends and the hottest skills
the career paths which will be demand so
let's start with the hottest skills in
the cyber security space in 2024 as you
can see there are so many skills which
will be in demand are in demand and will
be in demand uh in in the future so
Paris maybe can you take us through few
of these skills for folks to start with
someone who basically has no experience
in cyber security has no clue about
cyber security comes from a completely
different field uh maybe you can start
with something they can start with uh
maybe fews they can take up if they want
to explore C good right so so I would U
probably take couple of questions which
has been posted as well Russa and I'll
talk about uh so the first question that
I see is coming from Rajesh wherein he
says that he's an auditor and want to
move into the cyber security career uh
so what would be the path now being an
auditor it's like you you know multiple
faces of technology so I would say a
successful audit means that you need you
need to know at a bare minimum the
infrastructure from let's say Microsoft
Technology standpoint so you need to
know Microsoft servers uh operating
system you need to know the Linux
operating system you need to know the
infrastructure at a network layer it can
be paloalto it can be Cisco it can be
Juniper so you need to know these
infrastructure components so that when
you go and land yourself into an audit
you are skilled enough to assess whether
the controls implemented are correct or
not so so yes being an auditor requires
lot of technological depth uh as well
but does it require an absolute depth
from let's say somebody doing a pen
testing or somebody doing a threat
hunting or incident response the answer
is no so you need to know the topics but
you may not be the expert of all you can
definitely bring along bring along uh
domain experts along with you while
doing an audit nobody expect you to be a
master of all but you need to be a jack
of all for
sure uh the second question that I see
is coming from uh
jigan uh as a cyber security role do we
need to know Ai and ml the answer is no
you need not to know the AI and ml as a
for all the cyber security roles for few
cyber security roles you may want to
know the AI and ml as well uh it totally
dep depends on what kind of role you
want to pick it up and what profile you
want to transition or you want to
move into so it is not necessary to know
a ml for all the cyber security roles
the third question that I see is coming
from uh ryar Pai and uh he says that I'm
working as a security analyst but not
satisfied with the work I'm doing daily
I'm planning to move in security
engineer how can I pivot now uh it
totally depends on your background so if
you are currently into a technical role
like I said I transition from the it
management it uh not management but it
uh help desk to the system
administration to the software
development and then to the security so
there is a there is a path that you need
to Define and the the path will come to
you automatically is just that you need
to be aware in terms of U what you are
doing today and what excites you so if
you are already aware about the
infrastructure if you're already having
an experience on the it then being into
a cyber security at a technology site is
easier but let's say if you're coming
from a non-technology background but you
want to gain experience into cyber
security then uh probably a GRC or a
risk kind of a role would be a better
position and a better role for you uh so
so there are different roles which are
available in cyber security uh which
caters to wide variety of experience so
there is a role for everyone is what I
say so uh coming back to the uh roles
Russia I would say cloud security is the
one which is uh at the top of the bullet
as well but at the at the same time it
is very much in demand too uh lot of
organizations are moving towards the
adoption of cloud uh lot of uh share
market I would say is being mobilized
because of the cloud adoption by the
organizations as well so the moment you
see a cloud being adopted by an
organization it automatically means
reduction in the um CAPIC as well as
reduction in the uh dependency on the
human element for maintaining those
infrastru infrastructure component now
Cloud security is definitely one of the
space where in lot of hiring I would say
is currently being done be it Microsoft
or be it uh the uh the AWS or any other
uh any other player so Cloud security is
definitely one of the hottest Trend that
is there today uh Ai and machine
learning in cyber security is
evolving it is there but it is evolving
as as a field now it is good time I
would say to be in this particular
stream other than that vulnerability
assessment risk management threat
analysis these are definitely some of
the areas which have been there
traditionally and which uh which
basically uh remains a Talk of the Town
even today so yeah these roles do exist
and all are good in terms of the career
ahead uh thank you so much Paris for
answering a few of the questions from
the Q&A box and also taking us through
these hottest skills in the cyber
security space now that we've talked
about the skills here how can we miss
talking about the paths right so let's
talk about the trending cyber security
career paths in
2024 so so from a career path standpoint
uh security consultant for example is
one such role is one such path where the
opportunities exist there are big four
organizations like PWC deit Eren young
KPMG which hires uh constantly and very
very focused in a very very focused way
from the Market because they need people
to deliver on projects who are well
vered with the security uh parland and
the security areas so there is a great
demand of being a security consultant
there in in the market uh Cloud security
engine we have talked about there's a
huge vacuum I would say from a cloud
security standpoint even today while the
cloud has been there for long but then
Cloud security engineer role is still in
demand threat intelligence analyst p
testers these are the roles which are
not going to go away any point in time
what you need uh let's say from a pen
testing standpoint you need to be
focused whether you want to do an
infrastructure pen testing or an
application pen testing if you're
focused towards an application pen
testing and you are having a background
of a software development this is a
great great area for you to be in it
doesn't mean only the website or the web
application it can be a thick line like
a software that you are testing it can
be a mobile app as well that you you are
going to test by being into a
penetration tester so a lot of career
paths exist I would say these are just
probably 10% or 15% of what the roles
exist today in the industry uh but all
of this are or these roles are relevant
uh most of the roles that I see on the
screen requires the technical Bend of
mind uh but at the same time security
consultant can be a GRC consultant as
well wherein you should be aware about
the compliance standards the regulations
in the industry so those comes in very
handy uh by the virtue of being a
security consultant security analyst on
the other hand can be somebody who does
the it risk who is aware about the
security who is aware about uh the cloud
who is aware about the infrastructure at
an overview or an Uber level and and the
role becomes uh interesting there so
yeah these roles these career paths do
exist in 202 four and these are the
hottest one that I see as
well uh thank you so much P for sing us
to the training cyber security career
Parts in 2024 uh folks we would love to
know as we are nearing towards the end
of the year uh I'm pretty sure you're
here because you are aspiring a career
in cyber security or thinking about it
right so you can see so many of these
trending cyber security career paths on
the screen which Paris took us through
let us know what uh is the career path
in cyber security you are aspiring for
on the chat here so as you can see uh so
many career paths here security analyst
security consultant security engineer
security operations uh Center analyst
Cloud security engineer threat
intelligent analyst and penetration
tester ethical hacker so uh please uh
let us know what exactly is your career
path you are aspiring for or basically
already working on so you can let us
know on the chart here uh as we move on
uh let's talk about the salaries
salaries are equally important right uh
if you're getting into a field like
cyber security so uh so here as the
demand is soing so are the salaries uh
let me just quickly take you through the
Indian average annual salaries which we
have gotten through a source from glasso
so for a cyber security engineer here a
minimum of four lakhs is what expected
and a maximum of 12 lakh rupees INR
Rupees is what you can earn as a cyber
security engineer now for a cyber
security architect you can expect a
package of minimum 7 lakhs uh ranging
from an average of 20 lakhs and a
maximum 42 lakhs INR
and for a
CSO basically you can expect a minimum
package of 11 lakhs and average of 27
lakhs and maximum of 61 lakhs uh so
these are the in average salaries you
can expect uh in India in the upcoming
year and much actually much more than
that as well so and also let's talk
about the job growth here so uh cyber SE
and the US National Institute of
Standards and Technology estimate there
are 950,000 positions for the Cyber
Security Professionals
and 4 lakh 65,000 are unfilled uh and
cyber security Ventures projects uh 3.5
million unfulfilled uh unfilled cyber
security positions worldwide by 2025 so
uh we have a lot of job growth
opportunity here in cyber security field
so uh we would want to know what exactly
is stopping you from becoming a cyber
security expert here so let me quickly
launch this poll here so now this is to
understand what exactly are the
challenges you're facing when aspiring a
career towards cyber security or
aspiring to become a cyber security
expert here so you can see a quick fall
with which is launched now this is a
multiple choice question so you can uh
select multiple options here because
there can be multiple challenges or
concerns as well right when uh it comes
to taking up a career in cyber
security
awesome uh also for the folks who have
joined us live on YouTube uh please do
let us know if you have any questions
for our speaker Paris today and uh we
will take questions from the YouTube
live chat box as well and also let us
know what exactly are your concerns as
well when it comes to taking up a career
in cyber security uh so let me just read
out these options for you so the first
one is I can't find a program with a
fully comprehensive curriculum second
one I don't have the Practical Expos I
need to become job ready third one I
find it difficult to learn from
pre-recorded videos and the last one my
work schedule won't allow me enough time
for
learning so as I was speaking I see most
of the folks have already responded for
the polia we've gotten a really active
set of audience here uh so that's great
uh I'll just give five seconds more for
the poll here so last 5 Seconds folks
who are still sharing it uh so 5 4 3 2 1
let me quickly end the poll and also
share the results with you folks let's
see what Have you shared with us as your
challenge here what's stopping you so
what's stopping you for becoming a cyber
security expert uh we have gotten 56%
votes for I wouldn't get the Practical
exposure I need to become job ready 47%
for I can't find a program with the
fully comprehensive curriculum and 16%
votes for I find it difficult to learn
from pre-recorded videos uh 41% for my
work schedule won't allow me enough time
for learning so thank you so much for
sharing that with us that definitely
gives us a Clarity on what exactly is
the biggest challenge or what's stopping
you from uh taking up a career in cyber
security now let me introduce you uh to
the program by I kpur here the
professional certification program in
cyber security thre team by it kle comes
with the comprehensive and industri and
learning path you get access to
integrated handson labs and projects
which will be talking about in the
upcoming slides and how exactly these
projects are important for someone who
has no experience to Showcase in cyber
security also you get uh access to
online live virtual classroom so we are
not talking about only pre-recorded
videos here uh we are talking about live
interaction with the instructor and also
the student uh so that is how the
learning environment of the this
particular courses and also the program
duration is of 6 months so you can just
complete it by giving 10 to 15 hours per
week uh because initially I saw the
folks who have joined us most of them
have more than five years of experience
and few of them also have like you know
they come from a different set of
experiences as well so this program will
be flexible to fit your schedule in case
you're planning to take it up you can
complete it by just giving 10 to 15
hours per week also let's talk about the
eligibility and the pericos sites of the
program here by I Kaa uh you need to
have a basic understanding of
programming and cyber security a
bachelor's degree uh in a related field
with 50% or higher marks uh no work
experience is required for taking up
this program and also how this program
builds your uh cyber security skills
step by by step let me take you through
them so it starts with an orientation
session and uh then we basically move on
to ethical hacking and we basically take
you through through that and in detail
and then we move towards vulnerability
assessment and uh then towards pentation
testing and uh then we basically ended
with a cyber security caption project
which I'll talk more about in the
upcoming slide uh in a caption project
you basically get to choose from
multiple several domains you can uh
basically work from on a one caption
project which definitely will help you
showcase realtime experience in case you
don't have any in cyber security we'll
talk more about that the electives here
are basically by I compus academic
master classes to get access to through
this program and generative AI master
classes as well that is again another
new addition here in cyber security as
we saw IMG Technologies demand in IML so
we have implemented the generative VI
master class as well so the elective
here is optional so it is comes as a
part of the program uh and we don't
charge anything extra for that it is up
to you if you want to take it up and
let's talk about the cyber security uh
basically tools and platform this
program covers so we have a specialized
set of tools libraries platforms here
toolbox pentest tools n map kinix BB
suit Google dog W shark uh TCP Dum and
uh roex uh hping so here as you can see
we cover so many uh tools lities
platforms here so uh just a quick
question here I'm pretty sure folks
would want to know is here uh for
someone who's completely coming from a
different background uh what would you
recommend to to get started with in case
they want to explore cyber security
which this program also
covers so so I would say Rasha from the
tool standpoint there are variety of
tools I mean there is a plethora of
tools which are available uh be it from
a development Library standpoint or from
the operating system per se or from a
native tool perspective I would say some
some of the important one ones which are
like must have for people to know
includes uh the wire shock from looking
at the packet capture and deciphering
those packet captures perspective and
map from the port probing and
identifying the open and the closed Port
standpoint and these are easy tools I
mean these are not very uh tools that
you that would need somebody's years of
experience so these are very relatively
easy tool to learn
uh BP suit for somebody who is very very
interested in doing the application
security and application pen testing so
burp suit comes in a must for the
individual and I would say the mother of
all tools which is like K Linux is a
must for people who are in uh the cyber
space so if for example if I cover the K
Linux and BB suit I would say I am very
comfortably completing about 60 to 70%
of my journey in cyber security from a
tool Ling standpoint so so I would say
these are some of the important tools
that are that are mentioned here but
then priority wise I would go with K
Linux and the burb suit to start
with uh thank you so much Paris for
giving us an overview of these tools uh
as we move on uh as I mentioned earlier
you get to work on projects with real
business implications here so uh gain
access to a victim's machine uh is the
first project VAP on Bank application uh
vulnerability assessment and
exploitation and also capston project
which I mentioned earlier so the capston
project showcase uh basically you can
showcase to your future employees here
why a caption project uh they basically
mimic a real life business scenarios for
two experiences which you can Showcase
in your portfolio once you're done with
the program and you get to choose from
one out of several uh projects based on
basically the preference you want to
choose of from and also the capture
projects are reg in nature and provide
great examples of your work for your
port folio resume in case you are coming
from a completely non basically non-ice
security background and you don't have
any experience to Showcase this
definitely helps you mimic that uh
experience and gives you some kind of
work experience which you can uh
showcase to your future employer because
usually the openings which come from
freshers as well they do ask for some
kind of experience to Showcase so you
get to work on industry based projects
and also the cap projects we can add to
your portfolio definitely AMS up your
profile and also the IAT C recognition
uh definitely uh having that in your
resum definitely will help you learn the
job of your dreams as well now let's
talk about the job assess Service uh we
have uh here so we have partnered with
IM IM jobs here where you get access to
job portal uh with a wi employer Network
and resume review and rewrite Service as
well uh and a one-on-one interview
Service as well so these are the options
you get in order to basically help you
with uh getting a job all these are very
important uh once you have completed the
program it's very important to prepare
for it and have a you know kicka
portfolio uh through this resume review
and reite surveys definitely helps and
also uh having soft skills are really
important for interview prep so the
one-on-one interview service definitely
helps with the program so let me quickly
see I think you guys have shared with us
a lot of queries here and we have
answered a lot of
them and uh on YouTube as well we have
some questions here so um Paris we have
one question from uh YouTube live chat
box here uh Sid Paul is asking that
currently I'm working in an IT analytics
role so what should be my path to go uh
to a cyber security role
here so U so I would say see from uh
from an approach standpoint let's say if
somebody wants to get into a cyber
security role uh the CV is is something
which is like a mirror for or an
individual into into a panel as well now
when I look at uh when I look at a CV or
a resume of an individual there are few
things that I would definitely look at
is uh the the tools that an individual
has been exposed to the work that an
individual has been exposed to and the
self uh initiation or a self uh ignited
experience that an individual has done
based on that uh the interview can be
scheduled and once the interview is
scheduled uh people obviously can
showcase their inclination they can
showcase their experience the work uh
the excitement about the about the role
uh so having a very very clear resume
having a very uh Fair experience being
put together on a piece of paper is very
important because that reflects your
seriousness towards the role as well so
so yeah I I I think being an interviewer
being on the panel of interview as well
across across multiple organizations I
feel having a right resume is definitely
a key for landing yourself into the
interview position it doesn't guarantee
you the the job but at least you have a
say in the
interview thank you so much Paris for
answering that uh s Paul from YouTube
who has joined us please let us know uh
if that answers your question or if you
have any followup questions we have one
just opposite question Paris uh I can
see one question from nagaraju here uh
which says that I am uh from non IT
background with eight years of
experience and uh I basically want to uh
go towards cyber security what would you
suggest uh him see I think uh if
somebody has an a decent experience
which is like eight years plus
experience is a very very good
experience so I would recommend if a
person is coming from a technology
standpoint go with the profiles like pen
testing threat hunting so analyst kind
of a role but if somebody is coming from
a non-technology background or a mixed
technology background I would say go
into or land into the GRC side of it
wherein you can be a security assessor
you can be a security reviewer you can
be in the C organization as well so
those kind of roles would would
definitely be easier for him to attend
uh thank you so much for answering that
Paris I hope that answers your question
nagaraju let us know if you have any
followup questions and also for other
folks as well please do let us know if
you have any questions about cyber
security careers or uh basically uh the
program in general so now that we have
talked about the skills you know we have
talked about the career paths you can
take up in cyber security we have talked
about how the emerging Tex and cyber
security will be in vman uh not only
2024 but future and Beyond as well so uh
we would love to know are you interested
in enrolling into the professional
certificate program in cyber security
red team by IAT khur here so you can see
a quick poll launched on your screen
here where you can see the options yes
and no and you can share your interest
towards in enrollment uh by basically
sharing yes here I'll be taking you
through the enrollment steps of the
program after this uh they are very
quick simple easy steps and also the
program schedule and the program fee as
well so uh I'll just give 15 seconds for
this poll here as I'm speaking I see
that a lot of interest coming towards
enrollment so that's great uh meanwhile
I'll just quickly browse to the Q&A uh
here uh see and we have more questions
here um and uh see if he can answer you
so so Rasha I may have to drop for
another one sorry I have a hard stop
here sure sure sure but I really love
the energy on this particular webinar
and looking forward for attending more
questions and answering them as well
sure Paris thank you so much Paris for
joining us thank you it's always a
pleasure to have you have a have a good
good evening good night to you thank you
so much Rasha thanks
everyone awesome folks uh like I think I
see uh most most of you folks have
already responded for the poll here but
I see the polls are still moving I see a
lot of interest coming towards the uh
enrollment for this it compost
certificate program here in cyber
security uh I think I'll just give 10
seconds more here and for the folks who
have joined us on YouTube as well uh you
can let us know your interest in
enrolling into the IT scos red team
cyber security profession certificate
program here so uh last 10 seconds folks
you can let us know you're interest in
joining the program here I can see that
folks are responding yes on the chat as
well but please do share your response
on the poll as well that is how we
basically can reach out to you as well
so we might Lo lose your response on the
chat
so awesome I think last 10 seconds
before we move on to the enrollment
steps of the
program and uh lot of folks who have
joined us from YouTube as well thank you
for joining and thank you for being an
amazing audience
I see a lot of interaction on the chat
there going on there as well that's
great awesome uh I see that most of you
folks have already shared your responses
for this PO year so last five seconds
are you interested in enrolling into the
professional certificate program in
cyber security by urtin you can let us
know through the poll uh here which has
been launched uh would you like to
enroll into the program with an option
yes you can share sh your interest
towards enrollment here and I will be
taking you through the enrollment steps
of the program and also sharing with you
the program upcoming schedule and also
the program fee and also asking you uh
when exactly are you planning to enroll
uh just to understand so we can
basically reach out to you with the
admissions offer a letter and also
obviously simply learn learning
consultant will be taking you through
the program uh in much more detail
whatever questions you have as well so
there'll be a walk through of the
program as well which is required so I
think last five seconds I think only I
can see only few of the folks who have
not responded so last five seconds for
you folks uh you can share your
responses for the poll here so 5 4 3 2 1
let me quickly end the poll thank you so
much for sharing your interest towards
enrollment I saw a lot of interest uh
basically popping up through through the
enrollment here so how do exactly enroll
let me quickly take you through the
enrollment steps here so uh this is for
the folks a lot of you folks who have
shared interest in enrollment please uh
just pay attention for the next five
minutes this will be helpful so uh the
when uh basically the simply learns
learning Consultants will be reaching
out to you so they will be taking you
through this H small three easy steps to
follow which I'll just show you quickly
you need to submit an application to us
at ask us at simple.net based on that
application will be going for review
based on the eligibility and the
prerequisites I've shared with you
earlier and based on that you'll be
getting admissions offer from the simply
L Lear learning consultant team and also
they'll be taking you through much more
detailed work through of the program as
well as if you request them as well so
um I'll be sharing the email ID in few
minutes um here uh in the enrollment
schedule and the program fee for the it
compost professional certificate program
in cyber security rate team um the fee
here is 1ak 145,000 including taxes INR
and uh I think someone asked about if
there are any Emi options available so
yes we do have that for as low as
4,935 uh rupees per month uh and also uh
the immediate cohort which we have uh
which is start the classes starting on
20th JN 2024 and the induction for uh
this program will start of on 16th JN
2024 so uh for folks who have joined
from uh other countries I can share the
link of the program for you you can
check out for your own region and in
case you have any questions for us you
can always uh reach out to us if you
need assistance on this uh email ID by
ask us s.net I share that email ID with
you on the chat here I'm just doing that
only so you can just reach out to us
there in case you have any questions any
doubts please do reach out uh there I'm
just sharing that email ID quickly here
for
you awesome uh so I as I've taken you
through the enrollment steps here what
exactly you can expect from when simply
learning Consultants reach out to you uh
and also the program fee in the upcoming
schedule as well now you know the
immediate cohort which is upcoming so uh
we would love to know how soon do you uh
plan to enroll into the IT Kos
professional certificate program in
cyber security retine so this is for the
folks which is a lot of you who have
shared interest towards enrollment uh
this is very important uh now this is to
understand when exactly do you plan to
enroll so that is when we can reach out
to you as well and we have CS throughout
the year and we also make sure that we
take only limited set of folks for C in
order to make sure that you're getting
all the attention that is required when
you're taking up the program uh so just
to keep that in mind this PO is really
important because CS fill up pretty fast
pretty quick and cyber security is
pretty much in demand as you can see so
I think as I was speaking most of the
folks have already shared the responses
uh we have gotten folks who are very
active when it comes to interaction and
also polls but I think I'll just give
last five seconds for the poll
here uh four quick options here we have
uh first one is immediately upcoming
code which I've shared with you starts
on 20th JN 2024 that is next year and uh
for folks who are still thinking about
it and I'm not sure when uh when do you
want to start so I would suggest the
last three options here within three
months within six months and more than
six months from now you can select any
of these in case you're confused and as
I mentioned earlier we have cohorts
upcoming throughout the year and also we
take limited set of folks for
cohort uh I think last five seconds uh
because I see most of you have already
shared the responses last five seconds
for the folks who have shared enrollment
interest so 5 4 3 2 1 let me quickly end
the poll and also
uh I have one more uh
basically Poll for you we are just
towards the end of the session and uh
this is for the folks who have already
shared with us that they want to enroll
which is a lot of you which I saw at the
interest towards I conour cyber security
red team program uh so uh if you guys
need assistance in enrolling into the
program now this is for the working
professionals basically if you're really
busy uh we definitely can help you out
in uh you know enrolling to the program
they can give you that assistance from
Simply learns learning Consultants when
they reach out to you so you can let us
know through this poll
here okay uh sadar you will receive the
uh certificate uh by uh Saturday or
Sunday you will be receiving the
certificate for this webinar so please
don't
worry
also uh for the folks who basically uh
want the webinar certificate of this one
um you basically I'll just I'll be
ending the session now and uh for
sidhart I think he has asked a question
about the certificate only so and for
others for EXL uh so basically when the
webinar ends uh either you have joined
for your mobile laptop or desktop there
will be a popup by Zoom which says post
webinar survey there you need to fill on
your full name there and uh basically
once you fill up your full name there
which you would want to see on the
certificate uh you can also share a
feedback for us on if you have any
feedback on how we can make it better so
we can provide more value to you so I
think we are towards the end of the
session here thank you so much folks you
have been an amazing audience and uh we
basically uh will be ending the session
now because we exceeded the time by few
minutes I'm so sorry for that uh we
tried addressing all of your queries as
much as possible here and also on the
YouTube like chat box as well so so
sorry if you not able to answer all of
your queries but you can always reach
out to us at ask us.net I've shared that
email ID there in case you have any
queries you need more assistance please
do that I'm sharing that email ID once
again and for other folks who basically
would want to check out the um program
in detail I'll just share the link
towards the I cpost professional
certificate program in cyber security
red team uh with you so you can check
out the link to the program here as well
so thank thank you so much thank you
everyone uh we are basically nearing
towards the end of the year so Merry
Christmas to you wishing you a happy New
Year this is the last webinar of this
year so uh it's it's very special and
it's amazing to have you always and
amazing to host you uh always so thank
you so much everyone uh we'll be signing
off now and uh thank
you Happy New Year for FKS I I see
responses coming in on chat so amena
merry Christmas as well thank you thank
you folks we'll be ending the session
now you'll be seeing the post webinar
survey popup p in the session please go
and for basically fill your full name
there in case you want the webinar
certificate thank you so much folks
thank you thank you
everyone